Wendy una bambina londinese di 11 anni
sta dormendo nella sua stanza insieme ai
suoi due fratellini Joe e Michael
ad un tratto si sente come rumore di
vento e la finestra si apre
improvvisamente entravolando un
ragazzino stravagante tutto vestito di
verde con grandi ali alla schiena il suo
nome è Peter Pan
un ragazzino insolito un eterno
fanciullo il quale invita i tre
fratellini a seguirlo sull'isola che non
c'è un posto fighissimo dove tutto è
possibile dove non esistono le
responsabilità o le difficoltà del mondo
reale
Peter Pan è un personaggio letterario
affascinante e spensierato che
rappresenta l'essenza dell'infanzia e
della Libertà
ha deciso di non crescere mai di
rimanere sempre un ragazzino che gioca e
si diverte senza però pensare alle
conseguenze delle sue azioni
questa scelta
può sembrare sia allettante ma in realtà
è solo una forma di fuga dalle
responsabilità e dalla miniera che ci
aspetta
quella ideata dallo scrittore James
Matthew Barry è una fiaba magica e
commovente che celebra il potere
dell'immaginazione e dell'innocenza
infantile
ma allo stesso tempo anche le difficoltà
nell'affrontare il mondo adulto
in un certo senso potremmo dire che è
proprio Peter Pan rappresenta le
difficoltà per noi giovani di affrontare
il futuro
già
quale futuro
mentre le generazioni passate hanno
sempre avuto una certa fiducia nel
futuro
un giovane non siamo così ottimisti
guardiamo verso il futuro e vediamo
incertezza problemi ambientali e sociali
Non vediamo l'ora di raggiungere la
maggiore età ma allo stesso tempo
temiamo l'incertezza del domani
Cavolo quello dei nostri padri dei
nostri nonni era promettente il mondo si
apriva cresceva economicamente
Beh il nostro
dicono pensiamo sia dubbio oscuro
incerto
A volte
uno schifo
Durante gli anni abbiamo visto diversi
problemi passare sotto i nostri occhi e
così abbiamo imparato a riconoscerli
come crisi ambientale
la perdita di valori umani fondamentali
e perché no il repentino inarrestabile
sviluppo tecnologico
problemi che spesso ci fanno sentire
così piccoli così impotenti come in
balia delle grandi onde
Tra l'altro in un mondo dove le
divisioni
e lo spettro della guerra è sempre più
vivido
ora ci tengo a citarvi alcuni dati
prodotti dal Censis sul futuro I sogni
dei giovani italiani nel post covid
pensate come il 68% dei giovani
preferirebbe una società più inclusiva
mentre il 32 una più meritocratica
è un altro rapporto risulta come una
buona parte dei ragazzi abbia cambiato
la propria idea in negativo in seguito
alla pandemia
sembra quasi che come Peter Pan che
Cerca L'isola che non c'è tutti noi
cerchiamo a fatica e spesso con ansia un
futuro che non esiste ancora
siamo nella costante attesa di una
realtà
noi sconosciuta
Ora voglio porvi questa domanda
cosa ci spaventa in generale
nell'affrontare il futuro
come sappiamo il futuro è un qualcosa di
incalcolabile
impercettibile il futuro è Ignoto Da che
mondo e mondo
l'ignoto ci spaventa
Come avrete già sentito dire si lamenta
spesso che noi giovani siamo
disorientati e confusi
Forse perché a volte proprio le nostre
guide
sono disorientate e confuse a volte
contraddittori
viviamo in un mondo che ci impone di
avere tutto subito dove non si può più
aspettare attendere fermarsi un momento
riflettere
in una società dove il presente è tutto
ciò che conta
dove l'immediato prende il sopravvento
sul lungo termine
siamo abituati ormai a ottenere tutto
istantaneamente dal cibo alla musica
dalle notizie al divertimento
viviamo nel presente senza pensare Però
più di tanto al futuro
ricordiamo che ogni nostra scelta Ogni
nostra decisione ha una conseguenza è
che il nostro presente
influenzerà poi il nostro Avvenire
la mancanza di visione ci impedisce di
agire oggi per costruire il futuro che
vogliamo
Eppure
l'immaginazione è uno strumento
potentissimo che ci permette di creare
mondi nuovi realtà alternative
anche se tutto ciò che
sogniamo è frutto di ciò che sappiamo Ma
quanto sappiamo quanto conosciamo quanto
siamo in grado di sfruttare gli infiniti
strumenti a nostra disposizione per
arricchire noi stessi
quanto siamo in grado di scoprire il
mondo con occhi nuovi senza pregiudizi
bene
Noi siamo diversi da Peter Pan a noi
purtroppo non basta l'immaginazione
abbiamo bisogno di azione competenze
progettualità tutto per costruire un
futuro più giusto e inclusivo
nonostante tutte queste affermazioni
siano effettivamente vere penso comunque
dovremmo perseguire lo spirito che ci
lascia Peter Pan il suo continuo spirito
di positività e penso poi alla fine sia
quello che ci permette di andare avanti
allo stesso tempo possiamo
non crescere mai veramente
come lui sviluppare continuamente il
nostro senso
di immaginazione
ma nello stesso momento dobbiamo essere
responsabili e impegnati nel mondo reale
come Wendy che presenta appunto il
collegamento tra il mondo reale e quello
dell'immaginazione
quella costante voglia di portare le
proprie idee nel mondo reale
In definitiva
se proprio il nostro della generazione Z
è un futuro che non c'è
Allora dobbiamo solo crearlo insieme
[Applauso]